going to move on to the weather where
millions are still facing scorching
temperatures this morning from two heat
waves on both the east and west coasts
roads have buckled from the heat in the
pacific northwest
and officials say the extreme weather
may be tied to at least 12
deaths in washington and oregon lilly
luciano has more now from seattle
tanker trucks are hosing down
drawbridges in seattle to keep the metal
from expanding
and potentially locking the opening and
closing mechanisms
in place days of triple digit
temperatures
have caused roads to crack and pavement
to pop loose across the pacific
northwest
crews had to close multiple lanes of
traffic to repair
parts of this highway why is this area
so susceptible to that
as opposed to somewhere like say arizona
where the temperature drops at night and
then
rises into during the day every part of
the country that experiences high heat
like this ends up having some sort of
issue that they have to deal with it
doesn't happen as frequently here as it
does there because we don't often
experience high temperatures like this
this is rare
the number of people trying to stay cool
is also straining the power grid
in spokane washington where the
temperature reached 109 degrees tuesday
a utility company warned of rolling
blackouts due to the increased demand
during a speech in wisconsin president
biden noted the historic heat wave
as he called out climate change skeptics
116 degrees
but don't worry there is no global
warming
it doesn't exist as a figment of our
imagination
to deal with the rising temperatures
states from california to oregon
to here in washington are exploring
what's called climate resilient
infrastructure this means anything from
building roads with materials that won't
deform in the heat
to building higher bridges to account
for sea level rise
of course it could cost billions but
experts say the investment
would pay off in the long run gail we
like
we like ending with that this heat is
unforgiving thank you very much lilia